bruno cards ont fait le plein de son
tracteur directement sur son
exploitation du gazole non routier
achetés à des grossistes et stockés dans
cette pub c'est parti pour
303 3 408 avons le conflit ou crignon un
litre lui coûter 90 centimes c'est
partir en flèche dès le day que le
conflit a éclaté on est monté très vite
il ya j'avais fait une commande je me
souviens un euro cinquante cinq et sept
semaines l'as a même monté jusqu'à 1
euro 80 voilà oui donc à pratiquement ça
on a pris pratiquement 1 euro
sur sur notre litres de gasoil non
routier qu'on appelle génère donc pour
tout ce qui est en jeu agricole le
problème c'est que ces machines sont
très gourmandes en carburant entre les
semis l'épandage la récolte il faut
compter 100 litres par hectare chaque
ennemi avec un réservoir par exemple sur
un tracteur qui peut faire 500 litres
sur une grosse journée debout travaille
sur du semis ou du travail du sol on
peut vider le réservoir en fait une
remise de 15 centimes par litre accordée
par le gouvernement jusqu'en juillet a
permis de faire redescendre le litre à 1
euro disent mais le gazole n'est pas la
seule énergie dont le prix a flambé en
raison du conflit craignant
l'engrais azoté en partie composée de
gaz est de plus en plus difficiles à
trouver ça a été très difficile dans le
commander parce qu'il ya eu des
problèmes de d'approvisionnement au
niveau pack européens d'ailleurs le prix
si vous prenez le l'azoté liquide qu'on
avait pour habitude de payer
allez deux cents 200 250 euros jean
aujourd'hui la aujourd'hui tout de suite
ce matin on était à
700 euros 700 à 1 700 750 euros là donc
ça on parle pour une tonne voilà donc
vous voyez l'augmentation c'est du x 300
en hongrie impossible de maintenir les
mêmes rendements sur ces 280 hectares de
céréales betteraves soja et de colza une
plante pourtant peu gourmande en azote
sans engrais on serait sûrement plus bas
que la plante la barre en bas là voilà
on aurait une plante tout petit et avec
un nombre de ramifications et un nombre
de boutons floraux vous pouvez le
diviser par 3 sans problème donc on
aurait un rendement au lieu de cape town
en ferait peut-être une tonne le
problème c'est qu'il faut dès maintenant
commander l'engrais pour semer la
récolte 2023 mais impossible de savoir à
quel prix il vendra dans un an
maintenant l'inquiétude c'est est ce
qu'on va réussir à répercuter ces coûts
de matières premières ici nos premiers
maillons jusqu'à l'assiette du
consommateur c'est la grande question
en aucun cas nos agriculteurs veut être
la variable d'ajustement pour le moment
les cours des céréales et oléagineux
sont assez élevés pour compenser
l'augmentation des coûts mais les
cultures énergivores comme la betterave
ou l'endive vont subir de lourdes pertes
[Musique]